so we can get all of our panels to be
coming back on I first want to remind
the audience to register at
learnmxlogic.com
learn or slash projects for your free
learning portal account and if you
forgot earlier I'd like to encourage you
to do that now I'll put the link in the
chat box here so everyone can see it
if I get the setting right here we go so
you can make sure you get there and
click on the register free button so if
you can all do that that would be great
and we need to find Sarah to bring her
back in So Sarah if you're out there if
you can come back in we'd appreciate
that
and I think we're ready to roll so
gentlemen and ladies and gentlemen there
we go there she is uh we've got uh Dr
kashtari Kanan associate professor at
translational molecular pathology that
we just heard from Dr Sarah zapico an
assistant professor in the Department of
Chemistry and environmental Sciences at
NJIT Mr Elia Brody CEO of pine Tech bio
in New Orleans and Dr oskalov Who we've
heard of from earlier senior
bioinformatician at the department of
biology Lund University Sweden and the
science for Life Laboratory
ladies and gentlemen the first thing I'm
fascinated to know is how and when you
decided to get into this broad field and
of course your current Niche and I'm
going to call your name Elia let's start
with you
thank you yeah so
um
I I guess uh you know I uh came to this
field uh just because I was interested
in how uh data analysis could be applied
you know more in a more applied way you
know in more biomedical research kind of
application so I think that's the major
role in
um you know we we talked about how this
is being used you know to treat cancer
to study uh different important things
that I think are really much more
concerning than you know where
um a lot of things
in data science are being you know used
like marketing or something like that so
it seems like a much more compelling
reason uh to apply these skills to these
kinds of data sets
cool Sarah
well yes uh in terms of forensic
Sciences I said before I always wanted
to be a forensic scientist uh so as with
after my PHP
is because I see uh the potential for
the field in terms of uh for example in
challenging samples and implication of
human remains I ensure that
um although they are not
as using as everyday needs but uh I hope
in the future we can use in a regular
basis so for example the phenotyping uh
you know it would be really helpful to
edify human remains which I I mainly
what I do and yeah other things and for
example in there's of post-mortem
interval as well uh we have a really a
need for Technologies and I think based
on our preview research that is what we
need to apply this Technologies
uh just an observation before we go on
Grant I just noticed that you know we
had people here that dealt from
Childhood Cancer right so all the way to
kind of post more more to uh studies so
it's kind of interesting but there is a
distinct difference right so there is
applied and then there's research so
maybe as you describe your um you know
how you got to this maybe you could
mention so I understand Sarah you're
mostly doing research with this right
it's not actually being used
yes I am your research right now uh for
the moment it's not applied yet to the
field so with my son research what I did
in uh age estimation uh we were able to
apply to one or two cases but again it's
difficult because of the legal problems
basically and also it depends for
example when I talk about phenotyping uh
for example in New York it's really
difficult to apply in cases to determine
for example who was the physical
characteristics of the perpetrate so for
the big thing is different but still you
need to ask for permissions Etc so here
also the problem is legal is in terms of
with the genetic analogy although you
are I am sure you heard about a lot uh
you have still to
um ask for permission to use genetic
technology and at the end again you need
to do the strs uh the full DNA profile
so yeah the problem right now is the
actual application cases but slowly uh
we are trying to do it so so yes yes
it's our main limitations
fascinating absolutely fascinating thank
you Sarah Nikolai
you're muted
oh is he uh co-host or maybe
[Music]
there we go
yes sorry uh I think so I was trying to
unmute myself
um yeah so I'm uh originally from from
physics uh and um yeah this field I I
guess uh you mean how I moved to this
field broadly speaking to Life Sciences
I met a medical doctors clinicians who
showed me their data and I got
fascinated by the amount of open
questions basically compared to physics
I would say you feel in life sciences
and biology in biomedicine you feel like
a child in a candy shop there are very
many questions in physics you kind of
have a stable knowledge
uh accumulated over many many ages
basically
um in in life sciences it feels
differently there is very little
well-established knowledge which is good
for researchers because it's a curious
we want to know something
a new
um but maybe it's not good from the
point of view of um
patience because we would like to have
more knowledge
of course and help them
[Music]
okay thank you thank you much Dr Canon
will come back to you
uh well I mean like I said I was in a
medical research institute where uh I
was doing some core microscopy and then
uh I mean I've been a computer scientist
so in a biology
Biology Institute
so I think it was a logical uh
destination for me uh not to do some
bioinformatics and most of the
bioinformatics that I did was I learned
ad hoc I did not have any formal
training per se it's like trying to I
was like I'm I'm very curious uh to know
and to understand so so most of it is
like trying it out and seeing what it is
and stuff like that and initially you
have no idea of what the file formats
are even when I was introduced to Sam
and Bam files and things like that so
but most of the stuff is like uh for me
it's about being curious and trying to
figure out right I mean like using
computers I mean the terminal was at
hand the tools are there I mean nothing
really stops me from identifying or you
know doing discovering stuffs on my own
so uh you know I mean I learned it on
the Fly I would say and uh it's
yeah very cool very cool we want to
touch on careers in bioinformatics and
data science so open this up to the
group to discuss as you will how
bioinformatics is revolutionized
research what skill sets are required
for students to excel in these fields
bioinformatics and data science
yeah so maybe I can briefly start
um you know I think what is interesting
to see is that there is this diverse
range of data types and approaches also
depending on where they are used right
so as we saw today maybe in a clinical
setting it is very useful to have that
population level view so databases and
finding the connections between clinical
and omic state is very important in
other cases
I think that you know what uh was
um explained by uh Nikolai is very
applicable to the type of data that just
is starting to be generated right this
is not some widely adopted uh
translational research that is being
described these are Cutting Edge
algorithms and methods that still need
to be developed and validated I would
say right so so I think that depending
which direction you go uh bioinformatics
is becoming one of those domains like
data science that becomes you know
diverges like a tree into many different
domains so knowing where you're going
with this are you going to go to
clinical research are you going to
Industry uh completely different story
or are you going into research and then
which area of research I think really
will determine and help you understand
what kinds of skills but universally
speaking I think we can all agree that
you know coding databases these are
going to be your tools of the trade and
so so you should Excel and and know how
to do that and depending on whether
you're a developer versus user that's
also going to determine how much of math
and and statistics and kind of the
underlying algorithms you would need to
understand and you know potentially
develop on your own
we also like to jump in on that
uh okay let me jump in on that if
that's okay so one of the things is that
I feel that math and uh not math uh
forget mathematics but statistics on
Computing right those are the essential
skills that I think every high school
student needs to learn because the
applications are enormous so you can get
into any field that you want so
fundamentally if you are learning
statistics and programming uh whatever
type of programming I think those are
critical uh that we can build upon
biology or bioinformatics for that
matter right I mean if if social focus
our efforts of programming and
statistics in biology it becomes
bioinformatics naturally so those are
the critical skills I think uh any
aspiring bioinformatician or should have
or any anyone for that matter should
have and the second uh point that I
would like to focus on is actually
Network science learning some Network
science I mean we know that uh the data
are intricately connected and the world
is getting connected more and more so
learning some Network science will go a
long way uh in in applying the
bioinformatics bioinformatics into
useful into clinical practice so I think
these are the key two main things that
probably that people should be focusing
on statistics and programming and the
second is Network science
interesting nicolay or Sarah
y'all can just stay unmuted if it's
easier for you you don't have to keep
muting it's up to you
Sarah go ahead if you got your mute
button ready okay yeah I understand
so actually uh it uh use me my point of
view I was a student for five biotech as
you know so I learned a lot I mean again
uh you can be a developer or a user so I
think depending on uh what you want to
learn or what you want to apply you can
be simply a user I mean uh is what I am
uh learning from uh these courses so
yeah I think uh the skills again uh one
of the important things at least for me
when I choose a student is their
interests I'm going to learn I think
it's the most important thing and you
can learn everything if you are
interested in in the stuff yet so so
yeah not so much helpful but I think
yeah this is the point of a researcher
that uh I am mostly I use selling this
by informatics stuff
Nikolai
uh yes uh so what skills are important
um yeah I would say three types of
skills uh biology understanding of
biology uh programming skills and
mathematical background is also good to
have
uh yeah I I basically see uh maybe I
would say two types of bioinformaticians
it can be biologists you know having a
wet lab background who learned Computing
who learned programming and Mass to some
extent then there are also computer
scientists who come from from different
angles so they they can do linear
algebra maybe but they are not really
understanding cell biology and the both
I think can be learned so basically
people with mathematical background can
learn biology to some extent and people
from biological background they can
learn Mass to some extent
so I think
um but but talking about Lund University
I would say we still have a lack of uh
bioinformatics training so maybe because
bioinformatics is still it's a new
discipline so maybe there will be more
um by informations but we are kind of
still uh still there is no formal
training in bioinformatics it's as I
said it's either biologists who learn
maths and programming or computer
scientists who learn biology but there
is no like a separate education and by
informatics unfortunately
maybe if you uh just pick up on that I
think what we heard both from kasturi
and from maybe Sarah as well as you know
not always is it about those technical
skills right sometimes it's that
Curiosity that need in your project that
really brings you to the point of
learning and mastering a skill that you
needed at the point at the moment and
maybe another perspective on this
bioinformatics is a very diverse field
so it has changed significantly today we
heard about how it's continuing to
change and we know that the the pace of
change is just going to increase and so
so I think that's another component
right you have to be driven by your
ability to be curious find the answers
but also overcome challenges and that I
think is the reason why you need the
algorithmic perspective as well is you
need to be not only solving challenge
like a territorial that somebody gave
you but really trying to kind of solve
the challenge maybe in New Way Thinking
Out of the Box
you're muted Grant
sorry about that what would you say to a
chemist trying to join the trade that's
from chat
Nicholas since you were already up let's
let you take that one you start in on
that one what would you say to a chemist
coming into the trade
yeah I've seen uh people with chemical
background was but it was a background
in chemistry I think they uh have uh
relatively smooth
path to uh
biology wet Labs because they know all
the routines and they have similar I
would say similar standards
um I I mean it's not uncommon I think uh
chemists Who start doing protein
research I've seen many
people who Moved who migrated from from
chemistry to
biology and computational I think in
chemistry there is uh I mean the these
guys
they have a good education and um I
don't know quantum chemistry so it means
they they they understand
um some computer they they do have
um good skills in uh they should uh in
my understanding they should have good
skills in computational work so I see no
problems for chemists uh um migrating
too
to buy informatics
boom
let's switch over to what job
opportunities and internships for
students and researchers there might be
and Sarah I think did you have a job
available or something like that if you
did we'll start with you and then we'll
get the rest of the group
Yes actually I have a postdoctoral
position
but I am open to biologists biochemists
that are familiar with this data
precisely because we are going with a
different employees I have right now we
are going to work a lot with omics uh
for the moment we've
um
transcriptomics and metagenomics so yes
someone who knows how to analyze this
data so it doesn't need to be a
bioinformatician but at least biologist
biochemists who knows how to deal with
this statement so yeah they they post
yeah I think yeah it's already great I
think Elia just posted the link so thank
you for that and more generally uh what
do you think guys job opportunities
internships for students and researchers
well okay maybe I can jump in here and
just say that I think it's very critical
for people the students to have
opportunities to intern and maybe even
for free participate in a project right
because many times when you are taught
bioinformatics in a very standard way
you don't have the opportunity to see
the project as a whole and really know
how useful your work is so I think
internships and and especially
mentorship are critical so
um I know that uh kasturi you know you
do a lot of mentorship I think we also
spoke with Nikolai you you do some
mentorship as well I mean maybe you can
add on to this how does this actually
work in your organization you know is
there a process do you see
um you know where it's very uh critical
at what stage of that learning process
are these uh is it a critical component
because story do you wanna yeah so uh I
mean uh one of the things that uh we are
trying to do here is links we can talk
uh analysis uh and then it's important
for them Nikolai I think you were uh on
mute for a while and kasturi started
speaking at that time
I'm sorry I'm sorry go ahead yeah
no worries
oh okay so I mean I think uh you know
one of the key things that um I find it
challenging I mean in terms of uh uh you
know as you saw that we are developing
this systems framework which is heavily
dependent on bioinformatics and uh of
course and
um mentoring uh high school students as
well as the key thing is that uh
sustained effort is critical right I
mean on this uh you know learning some
bioinformatics I mean there are
opportunities uh very good opportunities
especially uh there's research that we
are doing is actually translational it's
directly impacting patients lives in
here and so uh you know there is uh
there are these challenges uh which I
say that you know it's it's about like
uh uh getting to uh you know like you
you exactly pointed out right I mean
it's not just uh about trying to learn
but also uh navigating the difficulties
that are you know on the way right I
mean having some troubleshooting the
errors and persistently doing that so I
mean I think uh these are critical
skills that are needed for any anybody
but then yeah we are uh we are training
people in there and so yeah our program
is expanding so what what was a critical
key question in this uh whether uh I
think I'm missing the point here what
what were you asking trying to ask
what what do job opportunities and
internships for students and researchers
might be either specifically with your
organization or general yeah so uh you
know as as this program expands
obviously there is going to be as I see
the future is going to be more uh
systems oriented and already there is
something called a breakthrough Cancer
Foundation that has announced uh you
know about 500 million dollars for uh uh
you know integrating data and data
integration and these are going to be
the key uh future prospects so I think
uh you know um if if students can get
trained on this aspect of bioinformatics
where they could all not just learn how
to do just the pipeline allowance but
how to integrate together to have a
meaningful patient driven systems then
uh you know combining with the databases
like the graph databases the cipher
query language I mean Cipher neo4j has
been like uh I'm seeing there are lots
and lots of opportunities that are
coming not only the buyer automatic
space but outside that are requiring
this graph databases knowledge so I
think those combinations will go a long
way in securing a good uh you know
internship and job opportunities for
students
good Nikolai
yeah uh So within our organization the
national bioinformatics infrastructure
Sweden we have a
uh by informatics advisory program so
all PhD students in Sweden and Swedish
academic
institutions they can have by
information a senior by information as a
mentor and it's very important so I
found it very important for for for the
PG students because very often
those guys
they come from from
um they don't have a good environment
don't have a critical concentration of
people who can talk analysis and they
they need to discuss
analytical tricks with with
analysts and sometimes I see that people
are sitting in the clinics they're
embedded into
into this clinical environment but they
want to do analysis and then for them
talking to
other analysts is absolutely critical
and this is what we are trying to to
help them with with this uh by
informatics advisor program so it is
very critical to interact
uh with other people who are doing the
analysis
fascinating that's really cool stuff
that's a nice nice program
I want to ask how the interdisciplinary
fields are integrated with multi-omics
if you guys want to pick that one up
well I was actually surprised to hear
about the way that Sarah is using uh
multi-atomics I I think so here we have
three different ways that multiomix was
described right Sarah was talking about
just using different omics to estimate
the same parameter and then because
story was talking about building a
database that has those connections
between clinical and maybe multionics
and then Nikolai was actually talking
about integrating them to see the same
experiment but just from different
perspectives and so I think these are
very unique different types of
challenges but
uh I mean
maybe it's a question whether multiomics
is a must is it just something that
happened to uh appear or is it something
that is going to be like a replacement
of a single Onyx I mean what does
everyone think about this
if I may go answering that I mean I
think it's a natural thing right I mean
whether we have to subscribe to the
single uh you know like I said right I
mean it's about protectionism versus
systems I mean interactionism is not
going to go this thing studying single
omics is going to be there there are
lots of things to uncover for instance
doing single cell sequencing I mean this
is about on a single cell level right I
mean so it's it's not it integrated with
a bulk population level so that's that's
there but then if you want to understand
uh in a very population-centric way how
we can put together to have
understanding uh you know in a holistic
fashion then obviously multiomics is the
way to go I mean it's ultimately uh the
difference in the philosophy whether you
know whether we are going to go
reductionistic or whether we are going
to subscribe to systems I mean from our
40 years or 60 years of uh you know uh
Decades of experience still we have not
yet gone to a place where things could
be translated to an actionable you know
where it can benefit a large class of
population so if you ask me I would um I
would uh you know I would place my bets
on systems biology so multiomics uh you
know is a way to go you know in terms of
understanding and in fact translating
the the biology to practice
anyone else
[Music]
all right let's look at some of the
strategies this is the next question
that's come up
um the strategies to evolve and involve
students in bioinformatics and data
science what kind of strategies do we
need to approach
and maybe before we jump into that sorry
but I see Ryan uh here has a good
question in the chat what are your
thoughts
on the interact Tome and study
integrative cell biology so I think it's
a little bit
um close to what Nikolai was describing
in his talk
I don't know if you want to answer that
um
[Applause]
yeah so by interact on
um uh I think yes talking about maybe by
interactive uh Ryan means uh sort of
network analysis and uh uh the graphs
that I was showing
um
those were graphs uh where each node was
one cell
or one sample one patient uh by
interrupting people typically I mean a
different thing uh they they mean um
maybe it's proteins then the nodes of
the graphs uh the the features
[Applause]
um
and um so I I think it's not exactly
what I was showing because
um my graphs they looked a little bit
uh differently exactly to drive Network
medicine yes this what Ryan is asking
um
uh I think it's a slightly different
Focus
um
how features interact and how how how
they're linked
um how they cluster
um
basically as I said in the talk you have
two dimensions in your data Matrix and
you can do cluster analysis and look at
the links between your statistical
observations patients samples or you can
do cluster analysis and look at the
linkage between your features I mean
it's two sort of sites uh
so I I'm I'm doing maybe more one thing
than the other
um so I'm not very much into the
interact home uh but uh it's uh
basically yes it is another way of
looking at the data and very interesting
way so I
so so I think that maybe you know since
we are coming to a close I I just want
to maybe spend a few more minutes I
think Nikolai
um you know mentioned this aspect of you
know you can look at either you know
sales or you can look at a lot of
robustness
um interact I think Nikolai sorry I
interrupted you because you were on mute
again uh but
um uh you uh mentioned how uh you know
the cell biology right is important here
because you are studying cell biology
ultimately by looking at these different
aspects I mean how far away is that
disconnected from then understanding how
those different features are linked you
know let's say the cell develops into a
certain phenotype there's some sort of a
you know separation of these different
cell types
do you look at all at what defines that
cell type afterwards I mean you must be
looking at what genes right or what
methylation patterns so so that there is
kind of like a way to go further and to
understanding how those clusters are
formed and what defines them right
uh yes so uh first of all uh you you
can't hear me because I think I I get
muted and unmuted randomly and it's not
me I think it's the network I think
you're networking right now hey I'm
sorry it might be on my side uh yes uh
um yeah so you're asking about uh
looking at the mechanisms so if you see
sales clustering uh if you see sales
clusters uh you yes you would like to
understand the
um what biological molecules drive this
clustering of the cells and if you have
the molecular uh information from the
cells yes you definitely want to
interpret this clustering so it's a it's
a it's a little bit like looking inside
your machine learning model so your
machine learning model can can maybe
find these clusters but then you want to
understand why
uh it's a next natural question
[Music]
um because you want to get a deeper
understanding not just see the Clusters
but to understand what they mean and
yes if you have the molecular type of
information from the cells you you
definitely can can look inside the model
and understand why
I hope this is what you're asking about
and I think that you know the next part
of what he is asking the network
medicine that's exactly what costuri was
uh talking about actually sort of right
so so so I guess uh you know as we are
wrapping this up
um you know how do how do these things
can where do they connect you know on
one side we have you know single cell
techniques that generate multi-atomics
data and we need to go deeper into that
data to really understand what does this
mean biologically and all the way to
population Health level you know to try
to identify patients that are very
different individuals that may be also
will benefit from identifying these
unique clusters of cells that might
drive metastasis or something like this
right so I mean where do these things
converge I guess
uh okay
can I answer this question or do you
want me to all right okay I mean I I
think this is uh I mean this is where I
think uh you know on like you exactly
pointed out uh the the cell uh level you
have these two levels on one hand you
have the population and you on one hand
you have this uh single cell level right
obviously they have to intersect and the
model that probably that will integrate
is again going to be a graph model where
uh we can actually uh integrate the
tables for instance that has these uh
you know specifics of cell like patients
who have those specific alterations I
mean these could be modeled based on the
graph databases I mean as I see it it's
not going to be such a huge problem
right now the problem is that we are
like trying to think these networks are
totally uh different and not looking at
a database level but less looking at the
just how these connections are from a
basic Network level right I mean even in
network there's a difference between
Network uh biology and systems biology
right that was my initial question
whether like okay why don't we call it
as Network biology it's still a biology
but why do we have to call it as systems
biology unless we have the power to
integrate any type of data that we want
that the graph databases provides us
with such a technology to do that right
I mean it's a very recent technology
it's it has a basis on wonderful
computer science right I mean pointers
and stuff like that so you know it can
be integrated but I feel that the
integration will go in the direction of
graph databases and it it cannot be just
thinking in things in isolation
Jasmine
anyone else want to pick that up
okay I'm not seeing Oh go ahead okay
okay sorry no because of the integration
of uh Technologies I know this is in a
completely different field you know uh
one of the things we are looking into is
the integration and combination of omics
for postmortem internal estimation so
it's kind of uh what I think you are
meaning in terms of health but uh in the
application of polensic uh science so I
think uh also the uh the integration of
the different omics could help in that
foreign
any closing comments
uh yeah I I understood the latest
question a little bit differently
Nation population versus single cell and
uh I I know I heard this opinion that um
typically when we work with single soul
data it's just one individual maybe and
then how does it generalize on the
population
um and I think it's still early days
um we will eventually
uh hopefully
reach this state that we can sort of
utilize millions of cells from from many
many individuals
um
sort of the question of generalization
of what you discover on on one
um one particular sample
um
it's still It is Well it so maybe all
the conclusions might not be
generalizable for the population but uh
still it's a those are early days so we
just want to see the heterogeneity
between cells and usually it's
consistent between individuals at least
the the types of cells talking about
maybe blood cells they're more or less
consistent
you see the same cell types from one
individual to another but indeed there
can be diseases where certain cell type
looks strange and
this is what we want to catch but the
more the more we sequence the more data
we have the the easy it will be to
answer a question
very good well I'm going to go ahead and
close us up we're at our ending time and
I'm going to put my closing in the chat
box also we want to make sure that we
thank our honored speakers today Dr
oscarlov Dr Julia panoff who was on
earlier Sarah zapico Dr Lisa taraneko
who is on earlier Louis Sakamoto and
Julia Brodsky so we want to thank you
all for being here today and for
contributing to this fantastic session
be sure to join us tomorrow for our
second day of learning thinking and
being challenged by our amazing speakers
and one last reminder and it's in a chat
box to sign up now at the omics logic
sign up page click the register for free
button get your free account and start
learning thank you all again we'll see
you tomorrow and yes the session was
recorded and will be available to those
registered thanks again see you tomorrow